ich bin der festen überzeugung irgendwas
möchte denn mir gerne an hängen alles
was er macht macht er aus dem grund und
mir zu schaden interpretiert das
verhalten des anderen schafft sich seine
eigene wirklichkeit
das läuft alles im kopf
[Musik]
ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll
ich kann mit dem kollegen nicht mehr
reden und arbeiten für sie schwierig
jetzt hier zu sein weil er schon so
verfahren ist handlicher wir wollen
überhaupt nicht hier sein genauso wenn
es beim büro und würden weiter arbeiten
naja mein chef hat gesagt ich muss jetzt
teilnehmen ja führungskraft rufen an und
sagen okay wir haben eine schlechte
stimmung im team
wir müssen und was machen dass ein
konflikt wir können nicht genau greifen
dass du die eine variante und die andere
variante ist dass die anrufen und sagen
okay meine kollegen drehen jetzt seit
zwei jahren nicht miteinander wir müssen
jetzt etwas tun
es gehen leute weil die von diesem
konflikt betroffen sind
die halten es einfach nicht mal aus
kurzem eine rolle
ich unterstütze sie beide gleichermaßen
ich schlage mich nicht auf ihrer seite
und ich auf ihre weiteren ich bin für
sie beide gleichermaßen da so dass wir
am ende
gruppen können sie eine vereinbarung
treffen mit der sie beide zufrieden sind
bei uns geht es um selbstverantwortung
und wir haben das vertrauen dass die das
selber regeln können die wir besetzen
die vorwürfe wir gucken worum geht es
dir eigentlich was ist los wie könnt ihr
wieder arbeitsfähig werden die kommen
halt mit ganz starren positionen und
natürlich ist es schwierig da in eine
andere ebene zu kommen weil wenn ich
über monate jahrelangen konflikt habe
dann können wir das nicht in zehn
minuten irgendwie diese menschlichkeit
und wieder vorbringen so wir möchten
alle wertschätzung erfahren wir möchten
eine vertrauensvolle beziehung wir
möchten ihnen anerkennung
und wenn sie jetzt so hören dass ihre
kollegin sagt okay ich wünsche mir
eigentlich dass er auch zuhört was geht
ihnen da durch den kopf
naja natürlich ja jetzt zum ersten mal
aber alles was ich sage wird doch auch
ignoriert ok empathie ist das zauberwort
also ich spiegelt ihre gefühle und
bedürfnisse was eigentlich brauchen in
der situation
und wenn ich das mache hat der andere
dazu und dann gibt es diese schönen
momente wo dann einer von der seite
kommt sagte es ist gemeint ok und dann
kommen diese aha momente
dieser perspektivwechsel und das ist für
mich persönlich der gänsehaut moment
weil ich merke die stimmung verändert
sich es wird ruhiger die die
kommunikation ist verlangsamt und die
kommen sich wieder näher die kann sich
wieder in die augen gucken wir gehen mit
einer perspektive raus und die haben
eine konkrete vereinbarung was jetzt zum
beispiel den arbeitsabläufe betrifft und
ich sage mal als nebeneffekt nehmen die
auch eine neue konfliktfähigkeit mit
didi wissen oder die suche schneller den
persönlichen kontakt um noch mal dinge
anzusprechen als ist vielleicht vor der
mediation getan hätten
[Musik]